maybe has come a holiday also known in
the US as just a plain old regular day
because nobody celebrates it takes an
offer even acknowledges its existence
look around on may first and you're more
likely to see people getting a head
start on cinco de mayo or sleeping off
the after-effects of Arbor Day than
actually celebrating Mayday this is a
pity because meaty has a long and
occasionally interesting history to
understand Mayday we first have to go
back to the medium ancient Romans who
only had four months january april
november and national frozen food
awareness month this was a problem for a
couple reasons first off the year was
only a hundred and twenty-two days long
which meant that farmers had to harvest
their crops before they were fully grown
and everyone was getting really tired of
eating baby corn and baby peas of baby
carrots and secondly they had to be
aware of frozen food way too often the
Romans knew something had to be done but
they didn't know exactly what until
Emperor Julius Augustus
september-october asst December is
stepped in he created eight new months
named five after himself and the other
three he called februari because he
liked to see people trying to pronounce
it and may and june because he owns
stock in a greeting card company and
they're easy to rhyme incidentally
national frozen food Awareness Month was
eventually renamed to March once
refrigeration was invented and people
could actually have frozen food instead
of just being aware of it all the time
now maybe itself was not originally in
May and in fact it wasn't even
originally called Mayday it was
originally called Belton and it was
invented by medium ancient pagans as a
way to recruit liberal arts students
from the local college they spread the
rumor that Belton was this day of
frenzied copulation with any creature or
object capable of generating moisture
and of course this attracted a lot of
attention Beltane was originally set for
the first of june that way they could
get an entire year out of the new
recruits before revealing that the
copulation was actually just symbolic
and while there would be pole dancing it
wouldn't be the sort they were thinking
of or the other sort they were thinking
of Beltane got the joking nickname
Mayday because it was supposedly the
when the hotter pagans would finally say
yes you may and of course the pagans in
the know ended up calling it Mayday
because if you were a maiden when it
started you'd still be one when it ended
and then some people called it Walpurgis
night because while purga sounds like
something dirty this nickname however
confused a lot of the new pagans and
come May first they showed up at the
designated Beltane area freshly washed
and carrying a knotted sheeps intestine
and in a spurt of irony without the
elder pagans to show them to the
symbolic dancing pole these confused new
pagans ended up having the very orgy
that they had been tricked into
anticipating while this may day ended up
being much more popular than the actual
belton by several orders of gratitude
and eventually they had to change
Beltane to may first just to keep up
then the 1950s happened and everybody
forgot that sex existed for a while and
made a return to a day of just dressing
up nice and dancing around a pole then
the 1970s happened and everyone realized
that that was stupid and made a stop
being celebrated and that's where we end
up today incidentally the emergency term
Mayday comes from the long-standing
tradition that when your plane is
crashing you immediately have sex with
the person sitting next to you the
emergency code was originally called the
passengers are all boinking each other
but that was too long so they change it
to Mayday which is shorter and that's
important when you're plummeting
you